i think a fantastic sunday roast is the
cornerstone of home cooking it's what
the rest of the week's meals are built
around and i absolutely love it but that
doesn't mean it can't be improved
to make the most out of my roast my main
course is the delicious stuffed roast
rib of beef
complete with tangy horseradish
yorkshire puddings
[Music]
but first i'm enlisting the help of my
eldest
15 year old megan to reinvent one of my
all-time favorite classic desserts
and mess bomb
right eat a mess what's the one thing
you love about is a mess i love the
meringues now this is a eaten mess
with a twist
what's the twist in it compared to the
normal one we're gonna freeze it so it's
almost like a sort of eaten mess bomb
wow now i'd like you to whisk the cream
please
half the strawberries are going to go
through the mix and half the
strawberries are going to be turned into
a coulis strawberries in first a little
dusting of icing sugar into the pan and
now the icing sugar will withdraw the
sweetness from the strawberries and
start caramelizing so let me show you a
nice quick way of whisking secret
whisking
is like 10 seconds on
and 10 seconds off
that way your arms don't get tired
now
i'm going to take the cream to a
three-quarter stage what is a
three-quarter mix so we leave some sort
of texture in the cream and that's what
we call
three-quarter whip
you've got a nice
soft peak
they're caramelized there you go you put
a little touch of water in there that'll
help
break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice
strawberry liquid
now to get it really nice and fine i'm
gonna blend it
on
and blitz
off
okay that's fine i want you to use the
back of the spoon
and push that
through the sieve okay now that way you
don't get those seeds it smells so good
i love this now nice this is the
exciting part
hold up oh mag
right now the meringue with your fingers
just crush
and flake the meringue into the cream
how big should i crush it dado
there
nice big chunks
okay lovely
oh you okay yeah come on rang in my eye
damn
to make this dessert even easier i often
cheat by using good quality shop port
meringues you know taste that's just
cream and meringue
wow it's a little tasty okay
strawberries in next a couple of spoons
of the cooling
now look at that now
to prepare the mold to transform the
traditional eaten mess into a frozen
bomb form a triple layer of clim film
adding water to the bowl will help the
climb film stick
as i pour that in i want you to spread
it down okay at the bottom and push it
down can you hear that crunch yeah the
line all right
now
fold the cling film over
put that in the freezer please
make young please
in the freezer she goes
[Music]
dessert done now for our main course
with a twist that is the rib eye we've
had that in the fridge not wrapped so it
sort of almost air dries and it
intensifies the flavor gross so much
quicker and there's less water in the
beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so meg and i are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one roasting tin
starting with the spinach and mushroom
stuffing
[Music]
a little bit of salt and pepper please
good girl
some of your left shoulder some left
shoulder thank you
in with the garlic and the mushrooms to
toss the pan you push down and pull back
down and push back off you go take your
time
push it down
and flip very good that's it push down
nice that was lovely and again
nice i'm gonna drop let's see well done
well done well then right we're gonna
sort of make a little well a little
touch of butter in the middle
now we need to start putting the spinach
in the middle piece
so you can push that down spinach is
cold so you're not going to burn
yourself
be confident in the pan
toss it and you'll see it wilting
and disintegrating away wow who would
have thought all that spinach could fit
in this pan because it's a very delicate
leaf it sort of cooks so quickly put
this all on your board now
and then i just want you to go
and give that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
want you to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely
good
now outside and come in gently
good
regroup
and take your time
yes
mmm right
i love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon tan that's right so you get
your little thyme stalks and you pour
down you sort of strip
lemon thyme in now tarragon it'll taste
brilliant with the beef
fantastic with chicken and fish roughly
chop the tarragon and i sprinkle the
fresh breadcrumbs so the breadcrumbs
almost sort of bring the stuffing
together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk
now with the beef this is the exciting
part
slice
with the bone and then come inside and
go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for daddy salt
and pepper
and then look we pack our stuffing in
there
this is amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold out there like that
okay
yeah i'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if we tie it too tightly what
happens the stuffing will come out
that's right
that's ready for roasting but we're
going to protect it and sit it on a
trivet
so a trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt
a couple of tablespoons of olive oil mix
that in i'm gonna pour my mustard powder
over the beef so this forms a really
nice glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours
for a delicious twist on traditional
yorkshire puds i'm going to lace mine
with fresh horseradish
[Music]
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs
adding only half of your milk at this
stage makes it much easier to whisk all
the lumps out
and if like me you like your puddings a
little lighter and crispier add a
dribble of cold water and add salt to
season
when you're happy your batter is lump
free whisk in the remaining milk
peel and grate horseradish
and add a handful to the mix
we can leave the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven
that is beautiful and this is where you
really need to let it rest how long
would you say to rest it for um i like
to rest the meat for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
yorkshire puddings in
i love using the rich dripping but
vegetable all is a healthier option
to get the fluffiest yorkshires your
tray and fat must be piping hot
for best results take your jug of batter
to the oven and pour the mixture in
there
it takes just 15 minutes for our
yorkshire puds to puff themselves up and
turn a delicious golden brown
with the yorkshire puddings on the way
and the beef rested we can finish off
the eater mess bomb run the bowl
under the hot water
twist
and pull
nice wow look at that beauty
it's amazing sit that
on
to your plate
now the finishing touches a drizzle of
the remaining strawberry coulis just
going to pour this over amazing flavor
and some grated mint chocolate
and that is a nice twist
on a classic eaten mess a delicious eat
and mess bomb
beautiful let's go baby
please don't drop that meg please it's
not a rounders match
dessert sorted and the beef is ready to
serve up lift that up place that onto
the board
parsnips parrots you can see why we kept
them in half they've got all that flavor
one beautiful big slice
for daddy
one for maggie and then on the side it's
stuffing the stuffing a bit that's the
best to die for
now fantastic yorkshire they're amazing
aren't they beautiful mm-hmm that's for
my daddy
and that one that's for me
beautiful roast beef
with a twist
wow
[Music]
these are my ultimate classics with a
twist
juicy river beef with horseradish spiked
yorkshire puds
and scrummy eaten mess bomb topped with
strawberry coulis and mint chocolate
dinner i'm doing a dish that every home
cook should have a recipe for a great
stick to your ribs stew here's my
favorite beef and ale with mustard
dumplings
[Music]
and helping in the kitchen is my
youngest tilly
[Music]
tilly
first things first i'd like you to
season the stewing steak
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flour going to do
dad the flour helps to brown the beef
our seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew
i feel a bit like marshmallows
they do feel a little bit marshmallow
don't they look at the size of the
chunks of the beef
i'm going to cut my carrots literally
similar similar size that's right does
that mean they'll cook equally that's
right now these are little pearl onions
i'm gonna put them in hole as well
everything
has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burn garlic before
oh matilda
she promised you weren't going to
mention that
what is that
time
time and what are they
bay leaves bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in
the beef goes in first okay
[Music]
beautiful color
remember the carrots thyme in
good go
garlic
pearl onions in
good
give that a really good mix up
[Music]
daddy stews are very easy to make
providing at the beginning you give it a
little bit of love
now that's all beautifully browned
that bin that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan
adding beer or stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
i want to add in a couple of teaspoons
of tomato puree please
in fact three please
because it's so nice
there's one final thing in there
cover this durian's date with a bee
stock give that a little mix with daddy
please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you
serve it oh yes is the garlic going to
be burnt no excuse me
right and we always put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
breathe that's right not make the stew
all watery into the oven at 150 please
teals for about two and a half hours and
now
you focus on your homework
fun
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato classics in one twice baked
bubbling squid jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute in butter and add a dash of
water until tender
[Music]
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and cook
through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato center
then mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
[Music]
right homework done yeah beef stew is
chewing stewing let's get on with our
delicious hearty pet art i've been
looking forward to this
you and i chef i'm gonna prep the pears
so if you peel
i'll top and tail
into quarters pears goes soft in the
oven very very quickly so we're going to
put them on a tart you'll need to leave
them whole half or in quarter
what's that in there
ginger that's right a stem ginger so you
stem ginger and fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup good girl and some
brown sugar to your quartered pears
and then just grab some fresh ginger off
here so it's a bit of a
different one to grate this because it
doesn't really come through like the
cheese no
i'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it it's so
easy to do
so give me your finger
that's my center point i want you to get
the pears going around
like that a really nice circle it's
difficult isn't it because the pairs
keep on sliding all over the place yeah
we've egg washed the outside and i'm
going to show you a little trick
so you lift that up so see egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
and the pastry forms this nice little
shelf like a little money bag are you
going to do anything with the spare
pears oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger
let me go around mike with your glue we
might glue just on top
tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully it's a bit like snow isn't
it now that glaze is the pastry so the
pastry has this really nice shine on
there as well finally the lemon on top
and then put that there
180 and in she
goes you smell the beef smells delish
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it look at that i want you to
just i was hoping you'd ask just have a
little taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
i'm not allowed anymore
dumpling time flour in please i'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour
next the dumpling essential suet
that makes the dumplings nice and moist
thank you
followed by a generous dollop of grain
mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round and i've
got a touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
my fingers are getting tired right now
put your hand in there now you should
bring
all that dough together
i'll show you the best way to get that
nice and clean sprinkle the flour on
your hands rub them together
all that will come off
that's a good way isn't it
now you've got this wonderful dumpling
mixture
how squidgy is that
a little flour on your hands okay
roll these lengthways
and then i want you to
fall in like that in your hand
i'll figure
smell that mustard in there
huh smell
oh
come on he'd never trust you with
something like that
yes please
silly
gently
let's go in
at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
put that back into the oven for 20
minutes to cook the dumplings now if you
open the door for daddy i'm gonna take
out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our pet art has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please
nice and gently all the way around good
girl
little taps
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job
now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look
delicious okay i'll check on the
dumplings
now
look
they've sort of doubled in size
well definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
i might have to have a quick taste
before we go
just to check i mean we don't have to be
sure we have to be very sure
[Music]
that is an amazing hearty beef stew with
dumplings right the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate hearty dinner a
comforting rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and ginger galette